foreign
so on the show Jade we uh we love to do
some like reaction videos right on Tick
Tock Instagram there's always some fun
money uh videos out there that we see
and sometimes I'm not gonna lie
sometimes before the show we're like oh
I'll do a quick watch or one of us sees
it and finds it before the show to play
it but this clip James came in during
the break and we have not seen I'm
scared and he's like I really want you
to see this clip live on the show what
we might find we said okay we are brave
courageous women Jade we can do this but
uh so we just heard it's about car loans
so that's all we know all right James
play the video
sir what is your car payment
mine is 13.25 and what kind of vehicle
is that it's a 22 Ford Raptor okay you
have another payment I do actually my
wife's hers is a thousand it's a 22 Ford
Expedition
hey ma'am what is your car payment
13.86 and what kind of car requires a
1386 dollar payment a 2022 two grand
Wagoner series three Hey sir what is
your car payment
I got a couple of them but the first
one's
1445. what kind of car is that that's a
new GMC Sierra 2500 Denali
yes holy crap uh
that's 11.61.
oh
my gosh okay so the video is I gotta
speak with a phone going through and it
looks like an office I don't even know
where they are asking different people
what their car payments are so they're
there on video it's a car dealership oh
it's a car dealership it's the people
that work at the dealership these are
their cars James y'all I can't speak
Rachel I'm talking about holy crap I can
I say that when I use an example when I
just use an example of a car payment on
the show and I'm like yeah you know a
500 car payment well yeah that feels big
we're talking we're talking in the
thousands I was prepared to talk about
the average car payment which is like
717. I was prepared to yell at people
for 717. my my guy has a 1400
1400 for car one for one car one car for
one car oh Lord so that's what's crazy
oh I'm sorry Rachel I'm sorry
give it some Vibes James you got this oh
my gosh oh my God Rachel go Jay just go
what is what is happening go people
aren't dumb
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
heard I got Rachel you are so kind and
you need to pray for me right now
because this is this is I've lost my
words it's the dumbest thing I've ever
heard 13 14 1200 on cars on one vehicle
you are stealing you are robbing from
your future you're robbing you're
robbing yourself I said it I said it
before the break I said
Rachel the car payment that is the thing
that is the gap that keeps the middle
class from becoming and Building Wealth
because if you invested that car payment
what it would be oh what it would be if
I I was prepared like I said I was
prepared to talk about the average car
payment 717 dollars right for one person
and if you invested that money just over
30 years at a you know 10 rate that's
over 1.4 million dollars yep 1.4 million
and then I thought okay because the
little article that we had here was
talking about how you know people are
paying shelling out more than a thousand
dollars a month on their cars and I'm
like okay well a thousand dollars
invested for that same term over two
million dollars two million dollars that
you can have two million dollars and I
just I hear we hear all the time Rachel
people well you know today in today's
economy it's impossible to get a million
dollars it's impossible to get ahead the
way my bank account is set up no the way
your bank account is set up is with you
spending all that you own a stupid
person spends all that they get that's a
that's a paraphrase from what the Bible
says a foolish man spends everything he
gets
y'all are spending everything you get on
a car note for what for it to be report
in a cart in a parking lot outside in
the rain while you're inside heating up
your Lean Cuisine in the microwave
you're not even getting to drive it
because you're working all day what
Rachel tell me to go away because I'm
not telling you anything I need to go
under the desk right now no you don't no
you don't no because Carrie here's the
deal it's the truth and what and what's
hard is that we hear day in and day out
the struggle that people are in yes and
the problem is for for a lot of people
I'm not gonna blame this on everyone but
for a lot of people it is the amount of
debt that they carry yes so then you
narrow it down to a car loan which in my
opinion I told you this at the break I'm
like it is it's the hardest it's the
hardest piece of debt for me to justify
in my head because people can say a
student loan my degree is going to give
me a job or this or whatever but a car
but but a car loan is an asset that goes
down in value goes down and it's a thing
that just gets you from point A to point
B and you don't have to have it right
you don't have to have this like
luxurious thing and then on top of that
yeah going into debt having that payment
where you could be wise and thinking
about future self and investing that
instead and still having a great car
like I'm not talking about you have to
drive a beaver the whole time you still
have a great car but you actually save
up and pay for you own it there's a
sense of ownership that other people
don't own your future and own your life
that's right and there are there is
something about that car payment the car
loan that whole that whole debt it is a
mindset shift and when you said it keeps
the middle class it does there look we
know and I'm sure this that I mean it's
the stat is changing all the time but
the last time I wrote it down 61 of
people living to paycheck to paycheck I
think I saw one recently that said like
73 people a percent of people living
paycheck to paycheck and i i s I did the
math on this I looked at a couple of
stats and it said 43 of people have some
sort of car loan like car loans through
the bank and then of the other 25 of
people have leases not like you know the
typical loan so if you add that number
up Rachel that is suspiciously close to
the 61 percent that are living paycheck
to paycheck and y'all are wondering why
you don't have any money out here
and the magic of the of the 1100 that's
back of margin in your budget month a
month if you didn't have that payment
that that paycheck to paycheck stat
would be totally different it'd be
totally different the paycheck the the
car note Rachel is keeping American
people living paycheck to paycheck it is
keeping you broke now we've yelled and
we have given myself high blood pressure
and all of the things my armpits are
sweating I love a jade race it's my
favorite let's talk about what you can
do instead let's talk I mean you guys
know y'all know my story can I please
just tell you guys especially and I have
to mention this because culture now is
very work from home work from home
culture 2020 did that Sam and I sold our
second vehicle back in what was it Sam
2010 and we were in one car family from
2010 until basically four months ago
one car if we did it and can I tell you
the amount of money we saved for two
kids yes so what does that look like
Jade like like walk people through
because people are hearing you and
they're thinking no because my you know
my I I need a car just like I grew up as
a one-car family yeah and so it's all
like what you said earlier it's
formatting your brain to go what do I
value what what do the world tells us we
need two cars and they need to be brand
new cars and but what do you value I
value being debt free my husband valued
being debt free and for us at the time
we had a Hummer an H3 Hummer and the
payment was like 457 dollars a month we
had a Jeep Liberty it was 303 a month we
sold the Hummer we were upside down on
it so we had to take out a small loan
for like two or three thousand dollars
but it freed up over twenty five
thousand dollars of debt for us you know
so we did that and we worked on one car
we paid off that one car and do you know
what we have now Rachel money Jenny and
a paid off car and then we bought our
next car we took those payments added
them up but pay for our next car in cash
and that's how you do it folks that's it
not much more to say Jade well done well
done this is the Ramsey Show